[Musik]
annyeonghaseyo
meine lieben Freunde und herzlich
willkommen ihr heute zu einer neuen
Episode Minecraft mit Luca Staffel 2 ihr
seht schon ich beweg mich hier direkt
wieder Sieg mich ganz einfach daran weil
wir für heute wieder eine Menge auf
unserer To-Do-Liste stehen haben die
Sache ist allerdings dass sie auch seht
dass ich mich jetzt gerade erstmal aus
meiner Hobbithöhle weg bewege und hier
zurück rein laufe wir müssen demnächst
auch generell mal die ganzen Items neue
rüberbringen uns weiter und sofort
jedoch muss ich mir erstmal einige Zäune
machen denn wir benötigen diese Zäune um
die jetzt beispielsweise mal hier vorne
hin zu leichtfertig Fichtenholz Sonne
machen ne ich habe mir jetzt gerade noch
mal Fichtenholz Zäune gemacht und die
werde ich jetzt einfach mal hier vorne
dran platzieren ich will auch gar nicht
mal so ein großes Gehege machen die
Sache ist allerdings dass hier auf jeden
Fall für rein sollen denn wir benötigen
dringend Leder und ich weiß dass ich
gesagt habe ich möchte keine Tiere töten
da bin ich mir selber in diesem Projekt
schon ofter perfekte da falsch gebaut
wer bin ich mir selbst in die & Break
leider schon das ein oder andere Mal
selber nicht so ganz treu geblieben die
Sache allerdings dass ich erst ab jetzt
machen möchte zuvor muss ich allerdings
wirklich noch ein paar kurze Kühe töten
denn ich benötige Leder für Bilderrahmen
hier vorne setzt jetzt auch einen
Fichtenholz Zauntor rein und auf die
Ecken platziere ich ganz normale Fackeln
ich mache letzter Zeit so viel mit
Laternen sieht man hier glaube ich auch
dass ich so ein bisschen die packe
vergessen habe es wegen dem vorne noch
eine drauf und dass sie wird jetzt unser
q-stall erstmal werde also nicht der
hier in Minecraft wir müssen uns jetzt
allerdings noch mal hier perfekt direkt
Weizenkörner holen um dann hier hinten
noch mal ganz kurz und unsere eisenhacke
rauszunehmen denn ich muss hier vorne
jetzt mal ganz kurz eben bzw noch eben
kurz diesen Ort hier nehmen und man
Weizenkorn hinzusetzen soll jetzt habe
ich hier Weizen und damit können wir
jetzt die Kühe holen bzw brauche ich
[Musik]
Biene ich brauche auf jeden Fall noch
ein bisschen mehr deswegen können wir
theoretisch auch von der Weizen hinten
vor der Höhle zurückgreifen ich habe
zwar gesagt dass ich das ja eingestehen
lassen möchte aus Gründen der Ästhetik
Sache allerdings hat sich wirklich ein
paar Weizen lange brauchen bevor ich
damit den ganzen Knochen jetzt voraus
gebe ich meine das hier wird ja eh
wieder nachwachsen kann ich das ja auch
mal ganz kurz eben Scheren zumindest auf
der einen Seite also die ist ja auch
noch weg zackzack zackzack 15 Stück
sollten auf jeden Fall ausreichen ich
ist schon
[Musik]
nein die Sonne geht gerade jetzt unter
oder ich werde mich dann noch mal ganz
fix eben schlafen legen hier in unserer
Hobbithöhle so dass wir uns dann die Tür
holen können und später in den Video
dann auch diesen Raum dort hinten schon
mal so ansatzweise fertig bei und die
Sache ist und deswegen sage ich
ansatzweise dass
die Sache ist dass wir leider noch nicht
alles fertig bauen können weil ich z.b.
für einen braustand den ich dort an
die Sache ist dass ich beispielsweise
Verein brauchst dann den ich dort hinten
eingeplant habe ja lohenruten benötige
die ich nun never Kriege und dort auch
generell nur in seiner Festung oder
Stronghold wir das heißt hier vorne sind
allerdings erst noch die Kühe übrig die
bei euch nämlich als immer zuerst mal
kann ich reden ist auch ein bisschen zu
warm hier gerade wer mich meinen Hoodie
zu warm hält denn diese Note gibt es in
WS
sind generell viele neue Sachen online
gegangen nicht nur dieser Hoody sondern
noch ein weiterer Hoodie noch ein
zweiter noch T-Shirts Tassen Socken
neues popsocket so schaut ihr mal vor
beim Luca Minus shop.de der Lounge
gestern war ziemlich ziemlich krass
danke euch die ersten Besteller bekommen
auf jeden Fall auch noch Autogrammkarte
dazu allerdings sollte sich heute
Minecraft gehen und während ich diese
Tür t gerade schon langsam aber sicher
rüber Lotse zu meiner Hobbithöhle bzw zu
dem Stall dort unten auf diesen gleich
sogar schon da muss ich auch mal ganz
kurz offenbar Kommentare eingehen denn
ihr wurde einerseits geschrieben Luca
das Buch kannst vergessen hast du
verloren im Stronghold als du gestorben
bist dass ich mich kaputt gegangen also
das Buch ist wirklich weg wir benötigen
also demnächst wirklich Kakteen
einerseits für grünen Farbstoff
allerdings auch um uns das Buch noch mal
danke Daniel da dir dafür auf jeden Fall
für den Kommentar verziert richtiges
Deutsch hat dann tut mir auch
geschrieben Luca dieses Loch Ness
Ungeheuer was du da im netter entdeckt
hast was da im Wasser war und eigentlich
relativ passiv und sich neutral
verhalten hat das tut dir nichts das ist
komplett friedlich und das kann man
sogar mit seinen besonderen Sattel
reiten den ich mir allerdings noch nicht
craften kann weil man dafür auch
besondere Dinge benötigt ihr kommt hier
nicht rein oder wie
Papa so guck mal einer nach dem andern
einfach also danke auch dir für dein
Kommentar und mir wird auch noch eine
Info geschrieben weil er dieses Loch
Ness Ungeheuer dass er ist angeblich
einen Leviathan oder so du wohl auch der
richtige Name geschrieben von dieser
knochenschlange ich habe ja
knochenschlange genannt und verheilt das
Ding bauen serpent wo wir auch noch
geschrieben das ist gefährlich greift
auch an und es tropft auch manchmal
einen Zahn wenn man diese Knochen
Schlange tötet mit diesem Zahn kann man
sich dann einen Trank Brauen mit dem man
unter Lava gucken kann was halt sehr
geil ist gerade für so Sachen wenn da
irgendwie weiß ich nicht ne verit Blöcke
sind oder Quarz oder keine Ahnung was
davon auf jeden Fall geschrieben danke
dafür eure Kommentare ich bin da
wirklich sehr gerade mal auf euch
angewiesen hat wenn er auch jetzt Tipp
hab dann schreibst du auch gerne unten
rein jetzt Ruhe ich allerdings erstmal
mit dem Weizen Rechtsklick auf unsere
Tür so dass die sich paaren können ich
bekomme ein Chief Mint die Hühnchen und
die Blümchen keine Ahnung was das jetzt
ist allerdings habe ich jetzt hier zwei
kleine Kühe und das heißt ich kann zwei
große Kühe
töten
es tut mir so leid aber ich muss es
machen ich habe sogar nur ein Leder
bekommen
ich weiß nicht ob ich die kleinen Kühe
jetzt sogar irgendwie Himmel so ein
bisschen schneller groß machen kann ich
will es euch mein ganzen 2c verballern
habe allerdings jetzt mein ganzen Seiten
aber halt mal schauen ob das Ding was
gebracht dass ich muss auf jeden Fall
leider noch mehr Kühe töten ist du mir
auch leid allerdings will ich euch jetzt
erstmal den ganz großen Teilen ist ein
denn wie ich mit den ganzen Sachen
zusammensuchen für die Hobbithöhle
so meine lieben Freunde ich habe gerade
20 Minuten lang diese ganzen Dinge hier
zusammengesucht ich weiß es sieht wieder
nach sehr wenig aus hat aber ein
bisschen gedauert weil ich immer auch
von hier dann hat er vorne rüber laufen
musste dann muss ich noch ein bisschen
Ton holen da hinten am Fluss und dann
habe ich auch noch zwischendurch ein
paar mckuen der gehe ich dann mein Junge
beigebracht habe die ich dann allerdings
auch zwischenzeitlich wieder zu töten
musste da bin ich halt wieder bekomme
ich weiß es tut mir leid allerdings kann
ich halt anders kein Leder bekommen
außer durch Handel das dauert dann
allerdings ich möchte jetzt mal mein
Haus bauen und mich danach um dieses
komplette Break kümmern und dass es
vorangeht allerdings möchte mich ja wie
gesagt zufrieden für mit meinem Haus
deswegen bauen wir es heute fertig also
zuallererst kommt hier vorne einen
Blumentopf in das war so ein bisschen
Sonne Schüssel darstellen wo man eine
Pilzsuppe essen kann irgendwie verbindet
Pilzsuppe war mit solchen gemütlichen
Häusern ich hasse auch Pilze und Suppen
sind auch nicht so mein Fall ist
allerdings würde ich sagen fahren wir
jetzt endlich mal mit diesem Raum Iran
denn hier vorne kommt ein Schmelzofen
hin dann eben zwei normale Öl von der
einfach für Ärzte damit schneller geht
und hier können wir dann unser Essen
drin braten und hier dann eine Werkbank
die Blumentöpfe brauche ich jetzt erst
noch nicht allerdings die Fichtenholz
falschen denn die kommen hier hier und
hier hin denn darauf platzieren wir zwei
Fässer und unsere Steinsäge ich habe mir
gerade noch mal kurz zwei Bilderrahmen
gemacht denn die benötigen wir nun hier
für hier soll nämlich ein Bilderrahmen
hin da rein kommt unser Eisenschwert das
macht sind wir hier unser Steinsäge ist
und dann hier drunter eine Laterne
sodass wir diese Fackel und auch diese
und diese Fackel komplett entfernen
können jetzt gehen wir von hier mit ich
in den Raum rein und bauen diesen
blockiert bin diesen und diesen und die
drei darunterliegenden Blöcke auch da
finden wir unser eisenspitzhacke umbauen
zack zack da können wir mal ganz kurz in
die Blöcke einsammeln und auf diesem
Blog ja denn nun setzen wir hier wieder
drei fackeln hin und können nun ganz
easy darüber zwz mir gerade auf dass es
einfach auf der Ebene hier machen können
dann ist es vielleicht noch ein bisschen
heller wie setzt nämlich jetzt hier
unsere Fackel hin und nehmen nun unsere
Fichtenholz Falltüren und platzieren die
so hier drauf dass wir einfach hier so
eine kleine Bank kreieren können also
zack zack zack wenn das ganze schließen
und hier vorne auch und hier vorne dann
auch noch mal hoch springen zack & BAM
dann habe ich nämlich so eine kleine
Ablage und können nun hier hinter 3
Bücherregale hinsetzen so dass das ganze
wie gesagt so ein bisschen wohnlicher
aussieht hiermit die ich soll nun
eigentlich unser braustand hinkommen so
dass man halt direkt wenn man reingeht
und den Gang jetzt zu Ende geht direkt
sieht Hey guck mal hier ist der
braustand will der Typ hat Geschäft in
Minecraft die death allerdings habe ich
dafür halt wie bereits zu Beginn der
Episode gesagt noch nicht die lohenruten
deswegen erstmal hier die Deko mit der
Laterne und einem fichtensee und hier
drüber müssen jetzt auch drei
Bilderrahmen ich habe allerdings gerade
erst ein und deswegen kann ich jetzt
erstmal nur einen hinsetzen da werde ich
jetzt einfach mal beispielsweise eine
Wasserflasche reinpacken so dass man
halt wie Hey guck ma braustand
Wasserflasche hier links soll dann noch
einleuchten Meutereien und rechts
netherquarz habe ich mir bei legt das
sind so coole Gegenstände werden können
an der Stelle auch mal ganz kurz gucken
ob sie die beiden noch mal ganz kurz
sich paaren lassen können die Kleinen
hier vorne die sind leider noch nicht so
richtig ausgewachsen aber hier ist
einfach mal rechts ich zum Teil bisschen
auf die drauf nehmen außerdem noch eine
Fackel gesetzt wie mache ich mal eben
kurz weg hier die
beleidigt sind nicht die Kuh schlagen
und so haben die Fackel die aufweckt
also warten hat einfach mal bis sie
ausgewachsen mit ich benötige halt
wirklich leider Leder
für die Rahmen aber zum machen wir dann
an der nächsten Folge von die Sache
jetzt halt auch dass wir leider die
Bilderrahmen nicht nur noch hier und
hier benötigen darüber nötigen nicht und
noch zwei sondern wir benötigen auch
noch hier ich hier hier und hier
Bilderrahmen deswegen müssen wir da auf
jeden Fall noch ein bisschen Leder
anstatt bekommen die Sache ist
allerdings dass wir jetzt erstmal mit
dieser Seite hier weitermachen können
dafür benutze ich jetzt erst mal ganz
kurz meine Axt um diese vier Blöcke hier
abzutragen das Fichtenholz können uns
dann auch ne ganz kurz auf sammeln und
dann hier drunter allerdings auch noch
mal die Steinblöcke denn jetzt müssen
wir zwei Blöcke tief gehen und wir
fackeln einzusetzen um nämlich hier
vorne Fichtenholz Fallschirm platzieren
zu können
das triggert mich hier unten platzieren
jetzt einfach mal Sandstein und dann
benötigen wir für hier drüber noch sechs
anständig mal eben schon auf meiner
Kiste nebenan hole wie kann ich jetzt
nämlich auch hier vorne dran setzen Sie
das alles hier auch die und abgerundet
aus es ist halt so ein bisschen der
Nachteil leider an dem Texturepack
allerdings hat alles ein bisschen
realistischer hat allerdings gerade
schon gesehen ich habe ich vorne auch
noch viel Fichtenholz falschen angemacht
um jetzt hier vorne und hier und zack
eine Eisenkette daran zu packen denn nun
greifen wir unser Turnier zurück und
kann hier erstmal patroon platzieren nee
da so soll es nicht aussehen die beiden
sollen sich verbinden und die beiden und
dann platzieren hier vorne noch eine
Truhe im können hier dann auch einen
Blumentopf hinsetzen mit einem Bild
drehen der hier auch ein bisschen besser
reinpassen würde also theoretisch eine
Blume also der Raum hier ist auch fertig
ist sieht schon wir haben zwar nur hier
und hier eine Lichtquelle ist es
allerdings trotzdem auch hier beleuchtet
bei dir drunter die Fackeln sind hier
vorne fehlen jetzt noch zwei
Bilderrahmen wo wir bereits Gesagten
netherquarz und leuchtenden beide rein
kommen die kann ich jetzt schon mal hier
vorne rein packen und was auch noch
fehlt ist hier hier hier und hier Halter
Bilderrahmen wo ich mir ja hier 4 bzw 5
mal gucken welche Blume am besten
aussieht die Blumen auf jeden Fall
vorbereitet habe ich packe jetzt auch
zur Änderung einfach mal hier vorne rein
jetzt müssen wir nur noch hier vorne für
ein bisschen Beleuchtung sorgen dafür
habe ich allerdings auch hier noch die
Laternen die hängen jetzt nämlich
einfach einen Block vom Eingang entfernt
hin und auch hier ein Block entfernt von
dem Übergang zu dem Raum dort vorne und
als eingang können wir dann auch so ein
bisschen noch mal zwei Blumentöpfe
hinstellen mitfahren dran und dann müsst
euch einfach Vorstand das hier noch im
Rahmen drankommen damit das schon ganz
cool aussehen glaube ich weiß jetzt
allerdings dass ich ganz kurz auch noch
mal das spinnenauge hier vorne rein
packen wäre und die Glasflaschen kann
ich nicht gucken was ich hier wie
anordne und was ich auch noch ganz kurz
machen wollte war es mal ganz kurz
schlafen gehen
ich bin schon beim 1 Stunde ich nehme
jetzt allerdings noch mal hier meinen
roten Farbstoff und werde zwei rote
wolle mir noch on top machen ohne jetzt
erstmal hier roten Teppich noch eben
machen so kann das habe ich mich vorhin
ehrlich gesagt vergessen weil ich den
noch hinten vor unserem braustand wo
noch kein Baustein ist jeden Fall
hinlegen wollte die Kühe sind auch schon
bisschen weiter gewachsen ich habe
allerdings leider kein Weizen mehr da
müsste ich ja vor noch mal ganz kurz
gucken das jetzt auf jeden Fall schon
ausgewachsen das kann ich mitnehmen dass
Franzi auch direkt neue an und hier
vorne ist das hier auf jeden Fall auch
neu also zwei neue Weizen habe ich um
die Tür dann auch mal wieder zu
Carnuntum erstmal dann auch zu gucken
welche Kuh ich von denen töten kann also
erst mal ganz kurz hier rein gehen sagt
du mit dir beispielsweise dann kriegen
die beiden Kind dann kann ich eine von
denen jetzt auch wieder ganz kurz töten
ist das Kind überhaupt
weileder okay perfekt das heißt wir
kriegen auf jeden Fall den Raum im Raum
stand jetzt noch fertig also jetzt erst
mal ganz kurz den roten Teppich nehmen
und den hier vorne dann platzieren am
liebsten bisschen wohnlicher aus und die
können jetzt auch hier vorne unsere
Items rausgehen dann müssen wir dann
gleich einfach mal schauen was
vielleicht am besten aussieht und noch
die StA spinnenaugen die Glasflasche
Damen 2. Glasflasche will ich jetzt
nicht dran packen allerdings können wir
beispielsweise mal hier was und
spinnenauge reinpacken zack das sieht
glaube ich ganz cool aus und hier Sonne
leuchtenden Beutel des sieht allerdings
jetzt sich auch relativ ähnlich ich
schaue mal netherquarz vielleicht ein
bisschen besser vielleicht auch hier
vorne da leuchten wollte gleich noch die
Glasflasche weg und einfach so zehn
Stunden später ich habe es jetzt einfach
mal so gemacht dass ich das netherquarz
in Mitte gepackt habe und dann links und
rechts davon die kleineren Block also
spinnenauge und Leuchten Tischleuchte so
bin ich auf jeden Fall zufrieden damit
und somit ist auch unsere Hobbithöhle
mehr oder weniger fertiggestellt meine
lieben Freunde deswegen will ich an der
Stelle des heutigen wie das auch beenden
danke für eure Kommentare und Tipps zu
den ganzen netter Monstern soll ich in
der nächsten Folge den Nether gehen
schreibt es in die Kommentare oder soll
ich in der nächsten Folge vielleicht
mich Barnum and hier überhaupt erstmal
kümmern dass ein bisschen reparieren mir
überhaupt das mal anschauen dass wir
haben gleich in der noch Kasse
Gegenstände überall versteckt Adorno
schreibst du denn und in die Kommentare
und wenn's euch gefallen hat an der
Selbstständigkeit einen Daumen hoch und
ein Video hier da bin ich mein Kanal
regt auf die Glocke wenn dir weitere
Videos zu verpassen wollte mein Mund
fusselig geredet wenn man da Stunde 15
Aufnahmezeit und wir sehen uns dann im
Nu
[Musik]